the aftermath of a Russian attack in the
northern Ukrainian city of chernohev
last year on the ground bodies of
civilians they've been queuing outside a
shop for bread when they were hit by
shells and Rockets 15 people were killed
dozens injured
so you were standing around here
Natasha narrowly escaped death that day
by taking cover by this wall she was in
the queue with her son and mother-in-law
she plays me a recording she made on her
phone
[Music]
we heard explosions near us it was very
close and then we saw lots of people
running everywhere
the time of the attack was a city under
siege Russian forces were surrounding it
and shelled it almost daily they
destroyed Power and Water Supplies
evidence of what happened is still
visible nearly everywhere
this is where people were lining up for
bread that day it is right in the middle
of a residential area and what
prosecutors in the city say is that what
happened on that day is a war crime an
indiscriminate attack on civilians
[Music]
law enforcement agencies consider this a
war crime because the main victims were
civilians also a pre-trial investigation
found no evidence of Ukrainian military
hardware that could be a legitimate
Target weapons were used
indiscriminately
all this
Mark seal marks are the three
places the buildings
works with the rights organization
called Truth hounds that's helping
prosecutors to build a case it's
collated evidence and used open source
materials satellite imagery and social
media to reconstruct what happened her
team says it's traced the killings to a
Russian unit that was positioned on the
outskirts of the city we identified also
the command of this brigade
who
might be liable and responsible for this
very kind of attack
whether Oleg Korean or another officer
was responsible for the attack on the
bread Q might never be proved some
investigators say he's back in Russia
it's clear that building legal cases and
Prosecuting alleged war crimes is a
challenge but for some ukrainians
pursuing Justice is at least one way of
honoring the war's many victims
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera chandnihiv
Ukraine